you've seen pictures from Boston this
morning where runners from around the
world are taking part in the Boston
Marathon the attack there six years ago
today inspired a government-sponsored
program that turns by standards into
first responders it's now being taught
at some schools stop the bleed teaches
students medical techniques like how to
tie a tourniquet and apply pressure to a
wound Don Dahler is in Boston with how
some students in the area are learning
about trauma care Don good morning good
morning you know it's been less than 20
years since doctors began teaching
civilians CPR and now a group of them
want to make trauma training just as
common with the growth of terror attacks
as well as mass shootings they feel it's
important to equip regular people even
students with those life-saving skills
this isn't your ordinary high school
science class but a lesson on how to
save lives trained nurses show students
how to apply the right amount of
pressure against a wound and to use
tourniquets to stop bleeding
so you have that's more pressure than
you ever thought you had to use it's
tiring yeah if you ever were in a
situation like that in a trauma most of
us can agree like we'd probably freak
out but this gave you like a little more
sense of confidence a person could bleed
to death in a matter of minutes
precious time that can't be wasted
waiting on first responders instructors
also mentioned that like at one point
like Adrenaline's gonna kick in and then
yours gonna have to get down to like you
know how to do this like trust herself
and that's the point of this training so
in the event of an accident
or an act of violence like a school
shooting students can perform these
life-saving functions quickly
dr. Reza Ascari and dr. Eric Guralnik
are leading this stopped the bleed
we can educate them we can then empower
them this is sort of where CPR was 40
years ago right instead of a heart
attack this is life-threatening bleeding
they were among the doctors at Boston's
Brigham and Women's Hospital who
embraced the program after tragedy
struck their hometown six years ago the
tipping point for us really in Boston
was a Marathon bombing and that
demonstrated to us that the public wants
to help three people died from the more
than 200 who were injured experts credit
bystanders and civilians who first came
to the rescue
it was part of the discussion at this
stop the bleed conference back in
February my story begins when my family
was standing at the finish line of the
Boston Marathon on that fateful day in
April 2013 Audrey Epstein Rainey's 18
year-old daughter Julia almost lost her
life when the bombs went off those first
few chaotic moments they first responder
at the scene rushed to our aid took off
his belt grabbed my husband's felt and
assisted us in putting tourniquets
on both of her legs and since trauma is
the number one cause of death for those
under the age of 45 plymouth public
school superintendent Gary Maestas felt
the program was important for his
students our kids will be prepared for
whatever they come in touch with
including Matthew absolutely absolutely
I think that's that's a that's a given
is there a risk that these kids are
gonna be traumatized by this yeah I
think the students that are in the
programs that we have and we offer they
have a great deal of understanding of
the medical fields that they are going
to be part of any concerns that you'd be
kind of squeamish in a real situation
but once you realize that
you know what to do to save this
person's life I think that will go away
and you'll just be focused on saving
that person's life it's most important
the doctors tell us that their ultimate
goal is to roll this program out
nationwide they also want to equip all
schools with one of these a tourniquet
for accidents or worse Gayle boy Don
thank you very much I do hope that they
roll this out nationwide yeah people
need this information sooner rather than
later
I like the idea of having those
practical skills yeah to show you
something that really can come in handy
and save a life
thank you again Don Dahler